[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le président de la république le premier
ministre
la tête de liste en marche
n'ont de cesse dans cette campagne de
montrer leur mépris pour la france de
droite le premier ministre
encore hier s'en est pris à ce qu'il
appelle la droite trocadéro
[Musique]
une droite trocadéro qu'il a expliqué ne
pas aimer mais ce n'est pas la droite
trocadéro qui ne l'aiment pas c'est la
droite tout court qu'il n'aime pas
aujourd'hui j'en ai la conviction la
france a besoin de nos idées de notre
courage et de nos convictions parce que
nous nous sommes ceux qui choisissons et
qui choisiront toujours la liberté
contre l'égalitarisme la responsabilité
contre la culture de l'excusé l'esprit
d'entreprise contre la bureaucratie et
la solidarité contre l'assistanat
nous voulons partager autour de nos
candidats avec françois-xavier bellamy
huit engagements je vous propose que
nous nous signons le neuvième engagement
c'est à dire de nous engager de toutes
nos forces dans les dix jours qui
viennent pour que cette liste face le
meilleur score possible et que nous
montrions qu'il n'y a jamais de fatalité
ce sera l'engagement de paris
l'engagement du palais des congrès ce
sera de 30 joueurs collectif
le boat utile pour l' influence de la
france c'est le vote ait l'air et l'air
ppe pour le 26 mai on a le droit d'être
européen
mais on a aussi le droit de dire et de
dire aux français on veut autre chose
une fable emmanuel macron ou qu'un
procès sans fondement marine le pen et
nous avons là avec françoise aviez
bellamy le plus beau et le plus grand
des candidats pour réussir ce formidable
de soi nous nous sommes à la fois
patriote et européen
dans cette élection vous pouvez faire
entendre votre voix
il y à une liste qui croient dans
l'europe il y à une liste qui porte ces
valeurs
une europe qui protège nos frontières
une europe qui défende son identité ses
racines chrétiennes face à l'islamisme
une europe des projets l'europe que nous
aimons cette liste et celle des
républicains de l'union de la droite et
du centre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de plus de voter contre votez contre
marine le pen voté contre monsieur macro
non nous ne voulons pas de ce cauchemar
ne voulons pas que la france traite
piégé dans un éternel second tour nous
voulons voter pour nous voulons voter
pour l'europe que nous voulons pour
l'europe que nous aimons pour la france
que nous aimons
quand l'europe veut elle peut
alors oui soyons fidèles à ce message
je vous demande de vous mobiliser
il reste dix jours françois xavier toute
son équipe compte sur vous
mobilisez-vous en avant pour l'europe et
pour la france
je crois une europe des valeurs je crois
une europe qui imagine son avenir dans
la diversité
les nations à leurs engagements et je
vous propose un chemin passons par les
sombres et comme le disait le général de
gaulle c'est généralement moins encombré
et bien je vous propose par les sommets
qui sont moins encombré de soutenir
notre lice pour que vive l'europe et que
vive la france
vous seul pouvez faire cette victoire
dont nous avons tellement besoin
vous seul vous n'êtes pas venus écouter
vous êtes venus agir
vous n'êtes pas venus écouter vous êtes
venu vous engager et dans dix jours
cette victoire sera la vôtre on refonde
l europe et pour rétablir la france
réaffirmer l'identité européenne pour
retrouver le sens de notre civilisation
mes amis nous avons besoin de vous
françois xavier a besoin de vous il y a
un espoir qui s'est levé dans cette
campagne une force que personne ne
pourra arrêter
je vous demande de nous aider dans les
douze jours qui restent aidez-nous pour
refonder l'europe et pour rétablir la
france je ne connais pas en politique de
plus grand ni de plus beau combat
vive la france et vive l'europe
[Musique]